Speaker 1: Here is an interesting voicemail
about vaccination incentives. We talk about
carrot versus stick. If you want to call
me, you can call two one nine two David P.
Any time of day, a few hints for voicemails.
Number one, don't leave me three five seven
12 voicemails in a row. If you do that, they
almost certainly are not going to be played.
That's one bit of advice. Second bit of advice
do not leave voicemails that are the full three
minutes long. We have never played a three minute
voicemail on the show. That's the maximum that is
allowed on our voicemail system. Voicemails tend
to be between 30 and 90 seconds. And number three,
get to your point quickly and this voicemail
does all of these things. It's 32 seconds long.
We can hear the caller clearly, and he gets
right to his point. And the question is
why are people getting rewarded for not getting
vaccinated in the sense that the longer you wait,
the more likely it is. You'll be offered 100
bucks or free sports tickets or whatever the
case may be. Take a listen, David seriously.
Speaker 3: Why aren't people getting rewarded
for not taking the vaccine? Why are states giving
people who haven't taken the vaccine money, right?
I really don't understand the logic
behind it. I guess it's like this
incentive thing, the carrot and
stick mentality, but it really
is. I don't like it. I got it a long time
ago. I was a participant in this fight and
this should get my hundred dollars right.
Speaker 1: No. Listen, this is a good point,
which is if you did the right thing because it
was the right thing to do early, you typically
got no reward at all. Now, some states said, we're
going to do a lottery, and no matter when you got
vaccinated, you can. You can enter to win a
million dollars or sometimes less, whatever.
But there are many cases where the incentives
get 100 bucks, get a gift card, get whatever.
They are only open to people getting vaccinated
after a certain date, and it only starts because
not enough people are getting vaccinated. So in a
sense, it is sort of backwards in that the people
eligible for the rewards are those who did not
get vaccinated when they could have and morally
speaking, when they should have. I get it. It's a
very good question, and it's something I continue
to struggle with. At the end of the day, I don't
really care because I just want people getting
vaccinated, but there's no doubt that the caller
makes a very good point. We have such a good bonus
show for you today. I can't even put it into
words. We're going to give you more results
from last night's elections, some of the less
prominent races. We're going to talk about them
on today's bonus show. Speaking of firearms, which
we just did, the White House is introducing a new
plan to reduce gun suicides. It's very common
that whenever you want to talk about gun safety,
right wingers will always say the real issue is
something else. You talk about mass shootings,
they'll say the real issue is handgun homicides,
not mass shootings, one off homicides.
And then you try to talk about those and they
say, Well, the real issue is suicides with guns.
Well, these are three different issues mass
shootings, single gun homicides and gun suicides.
Each requires a different approach and different
solutions, and the White House has a new proposal
for dealing with gun suicides. We're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show. And then lastly,
Marjorie Taylor Greene has, I guess we could say,
quietly accrued $48000 in fines for ignoring the
mask requirement of the House of Representatives.
Has she paid it? Has she paid any of it? Will she
be forced to pay it? We will talk about all of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com and you will get
instant access. I will see you there. Or sadly,
if you're not a member. We'll see you tomorrow.
But I would love to have you on the bonus show.
You can use the coupon code felony 21. It's
not really a felony to use the coupon code,
but these discounts are so extreme that
some in the audience imagine it's got to
be illegal this this such a big discount
can't be can't be legal. It's completely
legal. You can use the coupon code felony. 21.
Get the discount. I'll see you on today's box.